liebe Freundinnen und Freunde der CSU
herzlichen Dank für das sehr herzliche
sehr freundliche willkommen ich freue
mich heute morgen hier in Augsburg
bei Ihnen sein zu dürfen ich freue mich
dass CDU und CSU gut zusammenarbeiten
das haben wir gemeinsam Markus in
Hannover gezeigt und das zeigen wir
heute auch noch einmal in Augsburg
herzlichen Dank für die freundliche
Begrüßung
ich freue mich viele
Freunde Bekannte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Wegbegleiter
hier im Saal zu sehen das zeigt wie gut
wir zusammenarbeiten wie lange wir uns
zum Teil schon kennen
ich sag mal nur exemplarisch für viele
meine langjährige gute Freundin ihre
Landtagspräsidentin heute liebe Ilse
Aigner schön dich zu sehen eine große
Freude Manfred Weber unseren gemeinsamen
Parteivorsitzenden und
Fraktionsvorsitzenden im Europäischen
Parlament und liebe Freundinnen Freunde
eine ganz besondere große Freude für
mich ist ist Alexander Dobrind heute
hier zu sehen hier zu treffen in seiner
Heimat in seinem Land Bundesland Bayern
Liebe Alexander ganz einfach von dieser
Stelle herzlichen Dank für die richtig
gute Zusammenarbeit in der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
und wir beide wissen das das war nicht
immer selbstverständlich
und lieber Markus wir haben uns zu
Beginn des Jahres getroffen und einmal
über das Jahr 2021 gesprochen das war am
Kirchsee in Oberbayern das war ein guter
Platz in jeder Hinsicht und wir haben
uns eines fest vorgenommen so etwas wie
2021 so ein Anus horribilis das wird
sich nicht wiederholen zwischen CDU und
CSU
die Bundestagswahl am 26 September
letzten Jahres gut ein Jahr her
war das Ergebnis war die Antwort
zerstrittene Parteien werden nicht
gewählt
wir haben das schlechteste Wahlergebnis
bekommen dass wir in der Geschichte der
Union bei einer Bundestagswahl hatten
und liebe Freundinnen und Freunde das
war nicht so weil die anderen so gut
waren
sondern das war weil wir nicht mehr gut
genug waren und daraus haben wir die
Konsequenzen gezogen
und daraus haben wir die Konsequenzen
gezogen eine Bundestagsfraktion
eine Partei die CDU eine Schwester die
CSU die zu einem neuen miteinander
gefunden haben
und dieses Wahlergebnis vom letzten Jahr
haben wir angenommen
als einen Wählerauftrag
auch wir haben einen Wählerauftrag
bekommen
in Berlin im Deutschen Bundestag dieser
Wählerauftrag lautet
Opposition
Kontrolle der Regierung
Angebote Vorschläge zu machen was man
besser machen müsste wir sind nicht das
fünfte Rad am Wagen wir sind
konstitutiver Bestandteil der
demokratischen Ordnung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland ohne uns ohne
eine kraftvolle Opposition wäre die
Demokratie keine Demokratie und diese
Aufgabe füllen wir auch aus
und ich kann heute nach einem Jahr sagen
in aller Bescheidenheit aber auch ein
bisschen selbstbewusst wir sind mit dem
was wir jetzt gemeinsam in diesem Jahr
2022 auf den Weg gebracht haben wir sind
wieder zurück auf Platz 1 in Deutschland
liebe Freunde und Freunde
da sind sie in Bayern ja etwas mehr
daran gewöhnt als wir im Rest der
Republik aber wir sind es jetzt zusammen
CDU und CSU die Wählerinnen und Wähler
haben das Gefühl ja diese Union ist auf
einem ganz guten Weg die machen ganz
gute Vorschläge die schauen natürlich
immer noch auf diese Koalition und diese
Koalition hat das ist doch auch ganz
normal nach einem Jahr immer noch einen
gewissen Kredit
aber dieser Kredit wird kleiner wird
täglich kleiner er wird jede Woche
kleiner das zutrauen die Zustimmung der
Menschen in Deutschland zu dieser
Koalition dieser Ampel in Berlin
schrumpft
und das hat etwas mit den Themen zu tun
das hat etwas mit der Art zu tun wie sie
Politik machen das hat etwas mit den
Versäumnissen zu tun über die wir
sprechen müssen aber liebe Freundinnen
und Freunde dieses Jahr 2022 ist nicht
so verlaufen wie wir uns das zu Beginn
vorgestellt haben da gibt es ein Datum
und dieses Datum wird sich ganz tief in
die Geschichte Europas die Geschichte
der Welt
Einschreiben das ist der 24 Februar 2022
der Tag an dem der Krieg in der Ukraine
begonnen hat wir alle hätten uns das
nicht vorstellen können dass so etwas
noch einmal in Europa geschieht wir
haben uns 1990 auf den Weg der deutschen
Einheit gemacht der Vollendung der
europäischen Einheit wir sind zurück
nach Berlin gegangen die deutsche
Hauptstadt und waren eigentlich ganz
sicher dass in den nächsten Jahrzehnten
Friede und Freiheit Demokratie und
Marktwirtschaft nicht mehr aufzuhalten
sein werden und das war ich will daran
erinnern und will es sehr ernsthaft hier
heute sagen das war ja nicht nur eine
Annahme von uns
eine Naivität von uns sondern das war
auf der Basis von Verträgen die gemacht
worden sind nicht nur das Vertrages über
die deutsche Einheit nicht nur den 2+4
Vertrag der alle Alliierten
Vorbehaltsrechte über Deutschland
aufgehoben hat da gab es noch mindestens
zwei weitere Verträge die uns diesen
Anlass zum Optimismus gegeben haben das
war zum einen die Kater von Paris
ein Vertrag an dem 32 europäische
Staaten teilgenommen haben und die
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika und
Kanada und Russland damals noch die
Sowjetunion die erst kurz danach
auseinander brach in dieser Karte von
Paris haben sich alle Europäer unsere
Verbündeten
in Amerika und die damalige Sowjetunion
verpflichtet nur noch friedlich
miteinander zu kooperieren das Ende des
ksze-prozesses beschrieben und vor allem
das Ende des Kalten Krieges
und ich will darauf hinweisen liebe
Freundinnen Freunde weil es ja nun auch
immer wieder Missverständnisse in
Deutschland gibt Missinterpretationen
falsche Behauptungen die da lauten ja es
gebe ja Grund für Russland jetzt
misstrauisch geworden zu sein die NATO
näher an das Territorium von Russland
heran die Mitgliedschaft in der
Europäischen Union liebe Freundinnen
Freunde wir wollen doch die Geschichte
nicht vergessen im Jahr 1997 hat es
einen russisch ukrainischen
Freundschaftsvertrag gegeben bis zu
diesem Zeitpunkt war die Ukraine das
Land nach den Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika dass die meisten Atomwaffen
besaß
in der Annahme das Russland die
Verabredungen aus diesem Vertrag einhält
hat dieses Land diese Ukraine von 1997
an alle Atomwaffen abgegeben hat
abgerüstet hat das gemacht was viele auf
der Welt doch erwarten von uns allen
dass wir nicht rüsten sondern abrüsten
und alle diejenigen die heute immer noch
sagen bis hin zum Fraktionsvorsitzenden
der SPD im Deutschen Bundestag das
Waffen das Bundeswehr das Bewaffnung das
Verteidigungsfähigkeit das falsche
Signal sind für Frieden und Freiheit auf
der Welt der sei auf diesen Vertrag
hingewiesen liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde es ist leider immer noch so wir
müssen
verteidigungsfähig bleiben auf dieser
Welt damit wir Frieden und Freiheit auf
Dauer jedenfalls da wo wir leben
verteidigen können
[Applaus]
und deswegen
haben wir eine so intensive Diskussion
nach diesem 24 Februar geführt über die
Frage wie wir denn jetzt gemeinsam auf
diese Aggression auf diesen
Angriffskrieg auf diese völlig neue
Herausforderung vor dir wir stehen
reagieren können und dann gab es den 27
Februar 2022 morgens um 10 Uhr an einem
Sonntag hält der Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gibt eine
Regierungserklärung ab
und ich weiß nicht wie es den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag gegangen ist und
ergangen ist wie sieht das empfunden
haben Alexander und viele andere ich bin
an diesem Sonntagabend nach Hause
gefahren und habe das Gefühl gehabt da
haben wir einen Bundeskanzler erlebt
der die richtigen Worte gefunden hat der
die richtigen Konsequenzen daraus bereit
ist zu ziehen und der vor allem bereit
ist diese historische Aufgabe anzunehmen
jetzt wirklich etwas zu ändern in diesem
grundsätzlichen Fragen unserer
Außenpolitik unserer Sicherheitspolitik
unserer Verteidigungspolitik ja und es
hat uns etwas überrascht mit diesem
Vorschlag jetzt endlich dauerhaft so war
seine Formulierung ab sofort zwei
Prozent des Bruttoinlandsprodukts für
die Verteidigung auszugeben und ein
Sondervermögen von 100 Milliarden Euro
in das Grundgesetz zu schreiben um die
Bundeswehr besser auszurüsten wow
wir sind nach Hause gefahren und hatten
den Eindruck ich jedenfalls da macht
sich ein sozialdemokratischer
Bundeskanzler auf den Weg mit einer
ganzen Reihe von Fehlern von
Versäumnissen von falschen
Einschätzungen der letzten Jahre und
Jahrzehnte aufzuräumen und jetzt
ausgerechnet ein Sozialdemokrat geht
diesen Weg den viele von uns immer schon
für richtig gehalten haben der
Bündnisfähigkeit der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit neuer Prioritäten
in unserem Land und vielleicht konnte
das in einer solchen Situation sogar ein
sozialdemokratischer Bundeskanzler
besser tun als jemand von uns
aber schon am Tag darauf war klar und
Alexander und ich wir waren am Tag
darauf nochmal bei ihm war klar alles
was er da gesagt hat gibt er jetzt in
diesen Apparat seiner Regierung nichts
von dem macht der selbst alles wird
irgendwie klein gehexelt
runtergeschreddert runtergefahren im
Apparat dieser
ampelregierung und genauso ist es
gekommen heute im zehnten Monat dieses
Krieges fast auf den Tag genau neun
Monate nach seiner Regierungserklärung
müssen wir doch leider feststellen es
ist weitgehend eine große Enttäuschung
mit dieser Zeiten Wende die er da
ausgerufen hat es ist weitestgehend eine
große Enttäuschung
und liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
ich könnte sogar das Datum nennen mit
dem sich diese Enttäuschung verbindet
zeitenwände war das Wort vieles müsste
sich ändern nicht nur in der Bundeswehr
neue Prioritäten in Deutschland und dann
geht der Bundeskanzler zum
Jahreskongress des Deutschen
Gewerkschaftsbundes Anfang Mai und
erklärt den dort versammelten
Delegierten des Deutschen
Gewerkschaftsbundes es würde sich unter
seiner Führung im Übrigen in diesem
Lande nichts ändern alle Zusagen des
Koalitionsvertrages würden eingehalten
diese 100 Milliarden die sollten Sie
doch bitte mal akzeptieren das sei sie
notwendig das könnte man gar nicht
anders machen aber alles andere würde
bleiben wie vorher spätestens an diesem
Tag liebe Freundinnen und Freunde hat
der Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland die historische Chance
vertan und verpasst in diesem Land
wirklich eine Zeitenwende stattfinden zu
lassen an diesem Tag können Sie es auf
den Tag genau investieren wann diese
Chance von ihm verpasst wurde ich sage
das so deutlich
ich sage das so deutlich nicht weil das
der DGB war sondern liebe Freundinnen
und Freunde weil dies Wort Zeitenwende
vielleicht sogar nur unzureichend
beschreibt was wir im Augenblick erleben
der Bundespräsident hat gestern von
einem
Epochenbruch gesprochen
übrigens mal in
Fußnote hinzugefügt
das bei einer Rede des Bundespräsidenten
die lange angekündigt war und wo er sich
mit den großen Herausforderungen unserer
Zeit beschäftigen wollte nicht ein
Fraktionsvorsitzender aus der
ampelregierungssitzt nicht ein Mitglied
der Bundesregierung ist für nötig
befindet im Schloss Bellevue anwesend zu
sein ist ein Ausmaß an Respektlosigkeit
unserem Staatsoberhaupt entgegen dass
ich nicht für möglich gehalten hätte in
dieser Regierung
haben sie das noch in Erinnerung
als dieser Koalitionsvertrag Ende
Oktober abgeschlossen wurde welche
Überschriften da gesetzt worden waren
modernisierungskoalition wir gehen jetzt
ganz anders miteinander um es wird ein
ganz anderer Regierungsstil sein wir
machen auch keine Nachtsitzung und keine
Krisensitzungen mehr sondern wir sind
vorbereitet auf die Übernahme der
Verantwortung in diesem Land und ein
Wort stand ganz oben darüber das war das
Wort Respekt
kein Wort hat der Bundeskanzler
vermutlich in den letzten Monaten und
insbesondere in der Zeit der
Regierungsbildung so oft verwendet wie
das Wort Respekt ich kann nur
feststellen dieser Bundeskanzler ist
nicht nur in Deutschland gegenüber den
Institutionen unseres Landes dem
Deutschen Bundestag den wir dort kaum
sehen im Bundespräsidenten anderen
Institutionen gegenüber den Ländern dem
Bundesrat gegenüber wir haben noch
selten ich würde sagen in der ich von
meinem geistigen Auge ablaufen lasse
welche Bundeskanzler wir in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hatten wir
hatten noch nie einen Bundeskanzler in
Deutschland der so respektlos umgegangen
ist mit seinem Koalitionspartnern so
respektlos umgegangen ist mit den
Institutionen unseres Staates so
respektlos umgegangen ist mit unseren
Nachbarn so respektlos umgegangen ist
mit unseren internationalen Partnern auf
der ganzen Welt meine Damen und Herren
Respektlosigkeit steht über dieser
Kanzlerschaft
Epochenbruch liebe freundinnenfreunde
bedeutet dass wir jetzt vieles anders
machen müssen als vorher
es war nicht wie Francis Fukuyama
1991 geschrieben hat das Ende der
Geschichte
dieses Ende der Geschichte dass er nach
der Wiedervereinigung beschrieben hat
war nicht das Ende der Geschichte
sondern eine kleine Episode der
Geschichte von 1990 bis 2022
im historischen Zusammenhang eine kurze
Zeit und diese Zeit ist jetzt zu Ende
wir leben in einer neuen Zeit seit
diesem 24 Februar 2022 haben sich alle
Voraussetzungen und Bedingungen unseres
Zusammenlebens geändert und vielleicht
wird uns erst in den nächsten Wochen
Monaten vielleicht Jahren klar was das
bedeutet
zum Thema Bundeswehr habe ich schon
etwas gesagt
ich will den bundestagskolleginnen und
Kollegen hier im Saal danken Florian
Hahn als unser verteidigungspolitischer
Sprecher an der Spitze dass wir in der
Lage waren in der Bundestagsfraktion
gemeinsame Voraussetzungen zu
formulieren wie wir der Bundeswehr
helfen und das wie ihr gemeinsam mit der
Koalition helfen bis hin zu einer
Eintragung in das Grundgesetz aber ich
will in aller Deutlichkeit auch sagen
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde wir
brauchen uns hier von den
ampelkoalitionen wir brauchen uns hier
vom Bundeskanzler von der
bundesverteidigungsministerin nicht
irgendwelche Vorhaltungen machen lassen
dass dies doch nun alles nötig sei weil
in den letzten 16 Jahren für die
Bundeswehr nicht genug getan worden sei
diejenigen die dabei waren wissen in den
letzten Jahren hat es immer wieder
Versuche von uns gegeben der Bundeswehr
zu helfen sie sind an denen gescheitert
die heute die klugen reden über die
Bundeswehr halten an Olaf Scholz und an
Frau Lambrecht und an vielen anderen
heute
heute hören wir heute hören wir von
denen reden als ob sie nie anders in
ihrem Leben gesprochen hätten
Konvertiten Reden sind das 180 Grad das
Gegenteil von dem was sie gestern noch
für richtig gehalten haben mit einem
inbruch der Überzeugung als ob sie nie
in ihrem Leben etwas anderes gesagt
haben die Wirklichkeit heute in der
Verteidigungspolitik dieser
Bundesregierung sieht dagegen ganz
anders aus 100 Milliarden stehen im
Grundgesetz unter ungeheuren Zeitdruck
verabschiedet das muss ich jetzt alles
sehr schnell gehen die Bundeswehr müsste
Munition bestellen die hätte nichts mehr
die müsste liefern die müsste
nachbeschaffen liebe Freunde das ist
jetzt ein halbes Jahr her es ist nicht
eine einzige Bestellung aufgegeben
worden für die Bundeswehr es ist nicht
eine einzige Ausschreibung herausgegeben
für die Bundeswehr das sollte Munition
bestellt werden das sollten neues Gerät
bestellt werden nichts ist passiert bis
zum heutigen Tag und dann sehen wir in
der Finanzplanung für das ja
Bundeshaushalt 2023 eine Absenkung des
verteidigungsetats ich habe mich nicht
versprochen
2,0 Prozent ab sofort waren zugesagt
eine Absenkung des verteidigungsetats im
nächsten Jahr um 300 Millionen Euro das
ist die Wirklichkeit dieser Regierung in
der Verteidigungspolitik es ist das
Gegenteil von dem was sie uns am 27
Februar 2022 im Deutschen Bundestag
zugesagt haben und deswegen müssen wir
und deswegen liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde kommt auf uns eine Aufgabe zu
wir müssen die Partei in Deutschland
sein die ohne Wenn und Aber zu unseren
Soldaten und Soldaten steht die zum Teil
in einem außergewöhnlich schwierigen
Einsatz stehen
und ich war vor einigen Wochen in rukla
im Süden des Baltikums wo jetzt eine
ganze große Einheit der Bundeswehr
stationiert werden soll wenige Tage
vorher war der
Bundeskanzler da die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten dort haben uns berichtet er
habe mit einem Zettel vor ihnen
gestanden auf dem drauf gestanden hätte
und das hat er abgelesen bei mir steht
jetzt 20 Minuten Unterhaltung mit den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten also wieder
hochgeguckt und alle Soldaten und
Soldaten am unter sich geguckt
nach 20 Minuten
herumgedruckte waren alle Beteiligten
die Soldaten aber auch der Bundeskanzler
ganz offensichtlich froh dass diese 20
Minuten herum waren
wir waren da wir waren da liebe
Freundinnen Freunde und haben uns mit
diesen Soldatinnen und Soldaten über
zwei Stunden unterhalten
und dann bekommen sie ein Gefühl dafür
dann bekommen sie ein Gefühl dafür
was wir diesen Soldatinnen und Soldaten
zumuten und was die für unser Land
leisten
eine junge Ärztin Mutter von zwei
Kindern
Berufssoldatin macht ihren Dienst dort
in diesem Standort
und hat ihre beiden kleinen Kinder sechs
Monate nicht mehr gesehen und weiß nicht
ob das Flugzeug das sie abholen soll um
in der Rotation wieder nach Hause zu
kommen am nächsten Tag wirklich kommt
und pünktlich ist und sie zurück nach
Hause bringt liebe Freunde für diese
Menschen reichen nicht 20 Minuten weil
eben auf dem Zettel ablesen den muss man
sich zuwenden mit denen muss man
sprechen den muss man zuhören und die
müssen von uns diejenigen die sie in
diese Einsätze schicken das sichere
Gefühl haben dass wir unserer
Verantwortung unserer Fürsorgepflicht
für diese Soldaten und ihre Familien
wirklich nachkommen und das macht in
Deutschland nur eine politische Partei
das sind wir die CDU und die CSU liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde
ich stelle
ich stelle diese großen Fragen der
Außenpolitik der Sicherheitspolitik vor
alle innenpolitischen Themen
weil uns klar sein muss dass dies die
Themen sein werden die in den nächsten
Jahren darüber entscheiden ob wir ein
freies
demokratisches wohlhabendes Land mit
einem hohen Standard an sozialer
Gerechtigkeit bleiben oder ob das was
wir erreicht haben ernsthaft gefährdet
wird ich will es sehr viel deutlicher
sagen als es diese Bundesregierung in
Berlin sagt Putin muss diesen Krieg
verlieren und die Ukraine muss diesen
Krieg gewinnen da darf es keinen Zweifel
daran geben dass das so ist
wenn wir das im Unklaren lassen wenn wir
daran zweifeln lassen liebe Freundinnen
Freunde kein Land auf der Welt darf in
solchen Fragen
Zweifel mehr zulassen als Deutschland
gerade wir die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland in der Mitte Europas das
bevölkerungsreichste Land das
wohlhabenste Land in dieser Europäischen
Union darf keinen Zweifel lassen an dem
was wir in der Außenpolitik in der
Sicherheitspolitik für richtig halten
und das darf auch keinen Zweifel bei
unseren Nachbarn geben ja die Franzosen
sind ein komplizierter Nachbar und jeder
der schon einmal mit Frankreich zu tun
hat und Manfred du hast es fast jede
Woche jeder der mit diesen Franzosen zu
tun hat weiß dass das ein kompliziertes
Land ist aber ich habe etwas
verinnerlicht
und das hat mir mein Freund Wolfgang
Schäuble einmal gesagt und das geht mir
nicht mehr aus dem Kopf und das ist wie
ein wie eine Überschrift wie ein Mantra
für unser Verhältnis zu Deutschland
zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich er
hat mir einmal gesagt
der französische Finanzminister ist mein
Freund egal wie er heißt
ja liebe Freunde das ist innere Haltung
mit einem Land umzugehen wie Frankreich
zu sagen ihr seid unsere Freunde ganz
gleich wer zur Zeit Präsident ist wird
zurzeit in dieser Regierung ist und ich
will das gleiche gelten lassen für
unseren größten Nachbarn im Osten auch
dort haben wir schwierigste
Regierungskonstellation aber ich war da
und habe nicht nur mit der Regierung
gesprochen sondern auch mit dem
Vorsitzenden der piespatei ein verdammt
schwieriges Gespräch aber reden muss man
doch miteinander nicht übereinander
sondern miteinander in dieser
Europäischen Union und das gilt für
Frankreich das gilt für Polen
und liebe Freundinnen und Freunde ich
sag das hier in aller Klarheit das gilt
doch bitte selbstverständlich auch für
Italien wollen wir dieses Land jetzt nur
weil die so gewählt haben wie Sie
gewählt haben ausnehmen aus unseren
Gesprächen wollen wir die jetzt zu
paaria in der Europäischen Union
erklären glaubt irgendjemand ernsthaft
dass die Probleme des europäischen
Kontinents lösbar sind wenn wir die
Italiener ausgrenzen wenn wir mit
Italien keine Gespräche führen natürlich
hätten wir uns ein anderes Wahlergebnis
vorstellen können aber was maßen wir uns
denn an hier in Deutschland ein Urteil
darüber abzugeben wie die Wählerinnen
und Wähler in Italien in einer freien
offenen und geheimen Wahl gewählt haben
da hätte ich gerne die Aufregung an
anderer Stelle wo keine freien Wahlen
stattfinden da ist sie berechtigt
es bleibt schwierig aber wir müssen
reden miteinander
und nur dann wenn Europa gelingt haben
wir eine Chance diese Herausforderung
vor denen wir jetzt stehen gemeinsam zu
lösen ja ich bekenne mich dazu das wird
immer so bleiben meine Prägung kommt
nicht zuerst aus der Kommunalpolitik
nicht aus der Landespolitik nicht aus
der Bundespolitik sondern meine
politische Prägung und Sozialisation
kommt aus der Europapolitik ich habe in
diesen fünf Jahren viel gelernt ich habe
gelernt was geht und ich habe auch
gelernt was nicht geht und was auch
nicht gehen sollte und deswegen erlauben
Sie mir dass ich das an dieser Stelle
noch einmal wiederhole es wäre jetzt
wirklich auch an der Zeit dass ich diese
Europäische Union auf das absolut
Notwendige und richtige konzentriert und
nicht auch ständig so weitermacht als ob
es da keine Zeitenwende als ob es da
keinen Epochenbruch gegeben hat
und das sage mal bitte keiner das sage
mal bitte keiner das sei jetzt so ein
partei-tags Gerede von Unionspolitikern
wir haben sehr konkrete Vorschläge
gemacht dass man in der Bundespolitik
und was man in der Europapolitik tun
könnte wir haben es als
belastungsmoratorium bezeichnet ist das
eigentlich zu viel verlangt dass man für
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem
Land für die Unternehmen in diesem Land
jetzt auf nationaler und europäischer
Ebene mal über einen
belastungsmoratorium nachdenkt mal
darüber nachdenkt jetzt nicht immer mehr
noch mehr immer weitere
berichtsschichten immer weitere Kosten
immer weitere Hürden aufzurichten wo
wollen wir denn hin mit dieser
Europäischen Union wenn die sich
dermaßen über bürokratisiert wie sie
immer noch am heutigen Tag über
bürokratisiert ist das geht nicht mehr
das muss aufhören
und ich will es ganz konkret heute sagen
weil eine Allianz von Sozialdemokraten
europäischen Sozialisten europäischen
Grünen und leider auch europäischen
Liberalen gerade in dieser Woche ein
Beschluss gefasst haben man da kann man
sich wirklich nur an den Kopf fassen
jetzt im Jahre 2030 spätestens 35 den
Verbrennermotor zu verbieten und dann
wurde in Deutschland kolportiert ja da
gäbe es eine Revisionsklausel da könnte
man im Jahr 2026 ja noch mal nachschauen
ob das alles richtig ist und ob man da
nicht möglicherweise einen anderen Weg
geht lesen Sie mal das Kleingedruckte
das gilt nicht für PKWs das gilt nur für
sogenannte Sonderfahrzeuge also
Feuerwehrautos und Leichenwagen die
können überprüft werden aber für das
ganz normale Auto wird gar nichts mehr
überprüft das ist festgelegt gestern und
wir sagen von uns es ist nicht nur
europapolitisch es ist auch
innenpolitisch falsch weiter mit
Verboten Regulierungen Bevormundungen zu
reden das ist nicht Technologie offen
das ist verbohrt meine Damen und Herren
was da stattfindet
und damit bin ich damit bin ich jenseits
der Fragen von Frieden und Freiheit
vielleicht bei dem wichtigsten Thema das
uns in den nächsten Jahrzehnten auch
beschäftigen wird und auch heißt nicht
nachrangig sondern vorrangig wir müssen
uns mit diesem Thema intensiver
beschäftigen ich sage wir CDU und CSU
mit dem großen Thema des Klimawandels
große Teile der Bevölkerung draußen
glauben uns immer noch nicht dass wir
dieses Thema ernst nehmen dass wir
antworten versuchen zu geben und dass
wir uns hier mit dem festen Willen auf
den Weg machen an der Spitze zu setzen
zu liegen und nicht hinten lieber Markus
ich habe gestern Gelegenheit gehabt
einen Teile deiner Rede mitzuverfolgen
als auch über Bayern und über
regenerative Energien in Bayern
gesprochen hast Respekt für das was
deine Regierung die Vorgängerregierungen
zu diesem Thema hier in Bayern schon
erreicht haben großen Respekt dafür was
ihr hier erreicht habt
und wir brauchen liebe Freunde wir
brauchen uns von niemandem da draußen
irgendwelche Nachhilfestunden erteilen
zu lassen was wir denn zu tun haben in
der Frage der Energieversorgung dieses
Landes der umgekehrte Schuh wird richtig
es ist doch ein unglaublicher Vorgang
was da in den letzten Tagen und Wochen
in Berlin passiert ist um das Thema
Kernenergie
80 Prozent der Bevölkerung sind nach
diesem russischen Angriff Angriffskrieg
und nachdem Gas als Waffe eingesetzt
wird der Überzeugung dass wir in
Deutschland die Kernenergie für eine
begrenzte Zeit noch länger laufen lassen
sollten und was macht diese Koalition
wochenlanger Streit monatelanger Streit
und dann kommt am letzten Montag ein
Brief des Bundeskanzlers mit Verweis auf
die Geschäftsordnung der Bundesregierung
wer danach liest sieht da steht die
Richtlinienkompetenz des Bundeskanzlers
drin neben der Verfassung und ordnet an
es geht weiter bis zum 15 April 2023
meine Damen und Herren das ist eine
Entscheidung die kann man nur als
lächerlich bezeichnen wir machen uns auf
der ganzen Welt mit dieser Entscheidung
unseres Regierungschefs lächerlich
es ist ganz offen kundig es ist ganz
offenkundig der kleinste gemeinsame
Nenner zu dem diese Koalition noch in
der Lage ist in der Streiterei
insbesondere mit den Grünen und Markus
sich unterstreiche das was du gestern
hier dazu gesagt hast die sollen
aufhören über das Thema CO2 und Umwelt
und Klimawandel zu reden sie haben mit
dieser Entscheidung ihre Glaubwürdigkeit
endgültig abgegeben endgültig abgegeben
wenn man hier etwas hätte machen können
das wäre eine Entscheidung gewesen im
Sommer diesen Jahres
wir beide Markus Söder und ich wir haben
im August zusammen das Kernkraftwerk
Isar 2 besucht eines von drei das in
Deutschland noch läuft wir hätten zwei
weitere haben können die auch noch
hätten wieder zurück ans Netz gehen
können wir haben der Bundesregierung
konkret angeboten eine Sondersitzung des
Deutschen Bundestages im Sommer um
rechtzeitig vor dem Jahreswechsel neue
Brennstäbe für diese Kernkraftwerke zu
bestellen allein die drei wenn die
weiterlaufen würden könnten 10 Millionen
Haushalte in Deutschland mit Strom
versorgen aber nicht nur das sie könnten
die Strompreise um bis zu zwölf Prozent
absenken und zwar nicht nur in
Deutschland sondern in ganz Europa weil
das Angebot dann größer wird und Sie
könnten 14 Millionen Tonnen CO2
einsparen aus blanker Ideologie sind die
Grünen nicht bereit einen solchen Weg zu
gehen das hat mit Technik und
Freundlichkeit und Wirtschaftspolitik
nichts mehr zu tun
dass diese Regierung jetzt auch
wirtschaftspolitisch so in
schleudergerät hat natürlich auch etwas
mit personalbesetzungen zu tun die
weitgehend unterhalb des Radars der
täglichen öffentlichen Wahrnehmung
stattfinden schauen Sie sich mal an wer
im Bundeswirtschaftsminister Ministerium
Staatssekretär geworden ist meine Damen
und Herren das war für diejenigen die
sich mit Wirtschaftspolitik beschäftigen
die wissen das das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium war über
alle Stürme der Zeit hinweg immer ein
Ministerium in dem insbesondere auf der
staatssekretärsebene wirkliche Fachleute
für Volkswirtschaftslehre für
Wirtschaftspolitik zu Hause waren die
immer dafür gesorgt haben dass dieses
Ministerium das ordnungspolitische
gewissen der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
war heute sitzen da nur Ökologen nur
Leute aus dem Vorfeldorganisationen der
Grünen das ist eine reine
lobby-veranstaltung der Gruppen in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland geworden die
von Wirtschaftspolitik von
Volkswirtschaftslehre keine Ahnung mehr
haben und das war kein Zufall das war
kein Zufall
das war kein Zufall liebe Freunde
sondern das war das war die bewusste
Personalentscheidung von SPD Grünen und
FDP eine solche ökologische
Selbsterfahrungsgruppe an die Spitze des
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu setzen und
das Ergebnis sehen wir heute jeden Tag
in der Wirtschaftspolitik unseres Landes
und trotzdem bleibt richtig
dass wir uns in Kritik an dem was wir da
vorfinden nicht erschöpfen dürfen
wir müssen eigene Vorschläge machen wir
haben sie gemacht sehr konkret zu
Energieversorgung dieses Landes sehr
konkret mit unserer Klausurtagung in
Murnau Alexander zuhause im Wahlkreis
konkrete Vorschläge gemacht von denen
wir jetzt sogar einige wiederfinden
unter anderem in der gaskommission aber
auch da diese gaskommission hat vor drei
Wochen Vorschläge vorgelegt wie wir denn
aus diesem Problem herauskommen sollen
kein einziger Vorschlag der bisher den
Deutschen Bundestag erreicht hat und
liebe Freunde ich gehe noch einen
Schritt weiter
wenn wir es ernst meinen mit CO2 und
wenn wir dies als eines der größten
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit verstehen
und ich verstehe es so und wir alle
verstehen es so
dann werden wir uns noch mehr einfallen
lassen müssen als nur über Vermeidung
Verbote und Regulierung zu reden das ist
die Antwort von Sozialdemokraten und
Grünen unsere Antwort muss sein dass wir
in diesem Land
jede Technologie erproben jede
Technologie ernst nehmen jede
Technologie wirklich ernsthaft prüfen
die in der Lage sein könnte dieses
massive Problem der Menschheit ernsthaft
zu lösen und an dieser Stelle gibt es
einen ganz grundsätzlichen Unterschied
zwischen uns und Sozialdemokraten und
Grünen auf der anderen Straßenseite wir
denken nicht in verboten wir denken
nicht den Regulierung wir denken nicht
den Umerziehung der Menschen in
ständiger Gängelung der Menschen wir
sind der festen Überzeugung dass in
diesem Land in unserem Land in den
Universitäten in den Unternehmen nicht
nur bei den großen sondern vor allem bei
vielen kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen
ein solches
Innovationspotenzial steckt dass man
diese Unternehmen jetzt endlich mal
machen lassen muss man muss den jungen
Menschen und den Forschern und
Entwicklungen in diesen Unternehmen
Ansporn geben etwas zu tun etwas zu
erfinden
es kann sein dass wir mit der fusions
Energie
Weiterkommen es kann sein dass wir mit
eigener Erdgasförderung in Deutschland
Weiterkommen unsere Kollegen aus
Niedersachsen sagen uns wir haben in
Niedersachsen und im Norden Deutschlands
Erdgasvorkommen die reichen für 20 Jahre
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland glaubt
ihm ja jemand ernsthaft dass wir LNG
Terminals bauen dass uns andere Länder
Gas liefern was wir im eigenen Lande
nicht bereit sind zu fördern wir müssen
über dieses Thema reden nicht gegen die
Bevölkerung aber mit der Bevölkerung
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde und denkt
Verbote wegreißen Fenster aufmachen in
diesem Land das ist jetzt nicht mehr die
Stunde der Ideologen das ist die Stunde
der Ingenieure die wir in Deutschland
haben darum muss es uns gehen das muss
die Antwort sein
und jetzt komme ich mal auf Bayern zu
sprechen
was ist der Franz Josef Strauß hier in
Bayern
hoch anerkannt und draußen verspottet
worden für das was er aus Bayern gemacht
hat ein Agrarland das ist wahr Laptop
und Lederhose das ist wurde und heute
der Technologiestandort in Deutschland
es gibt keinen zweiten ich muss das
neidvoll anerkennen aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen kommen es gibt
keinen zweiten Standort in Deutschland
der so technologieoffen und so
technologieaffin ist wie Bayern das ist
ein sensationeller Erfolg ein
sensationeller Erfolg
bis hin bis hin in die heutige Zeit was
ist die Doro Bär was ist die Doro beer
verspottet worden für die lufttaxis was
ist der Markus Söder verspottet worden
für die Raumfahrt hier in Bayern und
heute reißen sich die Investoren darum
an diesen Unternehmen beteiligt zu
werden weil sie sehen dass das moderne
Technologien sind liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde ich liebe von diesem Parteitag
auch mit und auch aus dem was ihr
gestern und heute hier besprochen und
beschlossen habt wir müssen eine solche
Aufbruchstimmung in ganz Deutschland
erzielen dies Land kann mehr als diese
Regierung im Augenblick zulässt
ich will jetzt auf ich will es auf einen
ganz einfachen Nenner bringen wir müssen
mal endlich aufhören und ich sage auch
wir wir müssen mal endlich aufhören
ständig über aussteigen zu reden wir
sind kein Land von Aussteigern wir
müssen einsteigen wir müssen den
Anspruch an uns selbst stellen wieder
ein modernes Industrieland zu sein auf
das man in der Welt schaut und dessen
Produkte man gerne kauft und nicht über
das man in der ganzen Welt den Kopf
schüttelt weil wir hier einen solchen
Unfug machen wie das was diese Koalition
in den letzten Monaten und Wochen getan
hat liebe Freundinnen und Freunde das
ist der entscheidende Unterschied
und dann erwarten die Menschen draußen
von uns dass wir hier einen klaren
Kompass haben
dass wir wissen worum es geht dass sie
ernsthaft diskutieren miteinander wie
wir uns denn die Zukunft unseres Landes
vorstellen ja die Zukunft unseres Landes
liegt nicht in uns und dem was wir
können allein
es gibt kein zweites Land auf der Welt
das so abhängig ist von internationalen
Märkten wie wir aber das jetzt die
Regeln der Globalisierung
neu geschrieben werden müssen das müsste
doch eigentlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit sein wenn wir
heute darüber zurecht
klagen dass wir abhängig geworden sind
von russischem Gas dann kann es doch
wohl nicht richtig sein dass wir
sehenden Auges gleich in die nächste
Abhängigkeit marschieren was ist
eigentlich im Kopf des Bundeskanzlers
vorgegangen als er am letzten Mittwoch
diese Genehmigung für die Beteiligung an
einem Terminal in Hamburg ausgesprochen
hat er hat es doch uns gesagt in seiner
Regierungserklärung dass wir uns zu
abhängig gemacht haben warum macht er
uns denn jetzt an anderer Stelle in
mindestens gleicher Weise wieder
abhängig von anderen Ländern und dann
ausgerechnet von China
und ich weiß nicht ob der ich weiß nicht
ob der Mann kein Fernsehen schaut man
hat in diesem Amt wahrscheinlich relativ
wenig dazu Zeit aber diese eine Sequenz
die hätte er sich doch mal anschauen
sollen wie sein Gesprächspartner in der
nächsten Woche
zum Ende dieses Parteitages seinen
Vorgänger das war nicht irgendein
Querulant das war sein Vorgänger Hugin
Tao aus dem Saal abführen lässt in dem
Augenblick wo die internationale Presse
wieder zugelassen worden ist kommen zwei
Saalordner heben den Mann hoch und
führen ihn erkennbar gegen seinen Willen
aus dem Saal ab vor der Welt
Öffentlichkeit ja liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde ein brutaleres Zeichen der
eigenen machtüberschätzung der Macht
Vollkommenheit eines autoritären Regimes
als einen solchen Augenblick der
Weltöffentlichkeit zu zeigen kann man
doch gar nicht mehr machen ich hätte
erwartet dass der Bundeskanzler darauf
reagiert und dass er zumindest den
Anspruch erhebt während seines Besuchs
in China in der nächsten Woche diesen
Mann auch zu treffen um festzustellen ob
der überhaupt noch lebt nachdem was da
vorgegangen ist das wäre richtig gewesen
das wäre Haltung gewesen
stattdessen
stattdessen reist er jetzt dahin als
erster Staats- und Regierungschef
Regierungschef statt ist er nicht
Regierungschef eines westlichen Landes
mit einer Morgengabe im Gepäck
vielleicht sogar einer zweiten in diesen
Tagen wird noch darüber verhandelt ob
nicht eine chip-fabrik aus Dortmund
ebenfalls einem chinesischen Eigentümer
übertragen werden soll und dann schauen
wir uns mal an dem Abend nicht das
deutsche Fernsehen an sondern schauen
uns an diesem Abend mal das chinesische
Fernsehen an und schauen uns mal an
welchen Propaganda Erfolg unser
Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland diesem Regime in Beijing in
der nächsten Woche gibt es ist
ungeheuerlich das hätte kein
Amtsvorgänger vor ihm so gemacht wie
Olaf Scholz dies in der nächsten Woche
tut niemand hätte das vor ihm so getan
zu den Themen über die wir sprechen
müssen gehören aber eben nicht nur die
wirtschaftspolitischen
energiepolitischen umweltpolitischen
Themen zu diesen Themen gehören auch die
innenpolitischen Fragen über die wir
reden müssen und liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde ich will drei Themen ansprechen
die uns in den nächsten Wochen im
Deutschen Bundestag beschäftigen zum
Teil hat bereits die Beschäftigung damit
begonnen das eine ist das Thema
Bürgergeld
dies ist nichts anderes als eine reine
trauma-bewältigung der SPD
die Seite Agenda 2010 darunter leidet
dass sie ausnahmsweise in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland mal das
richtige getan hat
das haben die das haben die Funktionäre
der SPD die Funktionäre der deutschen
Gewerkschaften die Funktionäre vieler
Gruppen in diesem Lande den
Sozialdemokraten nie verziehen dass sie
im Jahre 2005 etwas auf den Weg gebracht
haben
dass die Bundesrepublik Deutschland in
der Tat verändert hat
zur Erinnerung wir hatten 2005 in
Deutschland fünf Millionen Arbeitslose
und zu diesem Zeitpunkt traten die
Gesetze in Kraft über die dann der
damalige Bundeskanzler die Mehrheit im
deutschen Volk verloren hat aber es hat
Wirkung gezeigt wir haben heute die
niedrigste Arbeitslosigkeit und die
höchste Beschäftigung die es jemals in
Deutschland gegeben hat und jetzt
Bürgergeld
damit das klar ist und damit da kein
Zweifel entsteht niemand von uns
bestreitet dass die Regelsätze
in der unmittelbaren Hilfe für Menschen
die in Not sind angehoben werden müssen
bei 10% Inflation müssen
selbstverständlich vor allem denen
geholfen werden die ganz unten sind und
die die Hilfe unseres Sozialstaates
wirklich brauchen übrigens
in dem Zusammenhang auch diese
energiepreishilfen diese
300 Euro es wäre besser gewesen 1000
Euro für das untere Drittel als 300 Euro
für alle das wäre unsere Antwort das
wäre unsere Politik gewesen
[Applaus]
nur wenn man jetzt in der Summe
ausrechnet hohes Schonvermögen
keine Beachtung auch eines großen
Immobilienbesitzes eine Karenzzeit von
mindestens sechs Monaten eher 18 bei dem
Nichts nachgefragt wird nichts mehr
erwartet wird und dafür hohe Regelsätze
erhöhte Regelsätze jetzt gegeben werden
mit der Folge dass es für eine größere
Gruppe von Menschen überhaupt keinen
Sinn mehr macht sich einer regulären
Beschäftigung im deutschen Arbeitsmarkt
zur Verfügung zu stellen insbesondere
wenn Sozialversicherungsbeiträge und
steuern so bleiben wie sie gegenwärtig
sind wir hatten mal einen anderen
Grundsatz übrigens geteilt mit den
Sozialdemokraten das stand sogar im
Gesetz das sogenannte Lohnabstandsgebot
übersetzt auf Deutsch diejenigen die
arbeiten in unserem Land müssen
grundsätzlich mehr Geld verdienen nach
Abzug von Steuern und
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen als
diejenigen die soziale
Transferleistungen bekommen liebe
Freunde und Freunde das war doch mal ein
gemeinsamer Grundsatz den wir hier
hatten
der wird jetzt aufgegeben
zu einem Zeitpunkt wo der fachkräft und
Arbeitskräftemangel mit Händen zu
greifen ist und möglicherweise eines der
größten Probleme unserer Volkswirtschaft
zu drohen wird
und in diesem Zusammenhang dann
einwandlung
damit auch da kein Zweifel bei ihnen
aufkommt
ich habe immer schon die feste
Auffassung vertreten und viele mit mir
nicht alle aber viele das Deutschland
ein Einwanderungsland ist wir sind ein
Land von Einwanderung überwiegend wenn
auch nicht ausschließlich ein Land
ungeregelter Einwanderung mit
erheblichen Problemen die wir
mittlerweile in Deutschland haben die
wir sehen wir auch
zu einer gewissen Spannung zwischen CDU
und CSU vor Jahr und Tag beigetragen
haben es droht uns in diesem Jahr wieder
eine sehr hohe Zahl von Flüchtlingen
Asylbewerbern
Bürgerkriegsflüchtlingen insbesondere
solcher die über die Balkanroute nach
Deutschland kommen wir fordern die
Bundesregierung auf
vorbereitet zu sein darauf dass wir
möglicherweise durch ein singuläres
Ereignis oder aber durch die dauerhaften
Krisen im Osten im Mittleren Osten im
Osten des europäischen Kontinents
vorbereitet sein müssen auf eine größere
Zahl von Flüchtlingen in diesem Land und
ich will hier für die Unionsfraktion und
für die CDU feststellen wir werden
keiner Politik die Hand reichen
die dafür sorgt dass die
illegale Migration nach Deutschland auf
welchem Weg auch immer legalisiert wird
indem wir hier zusätzliche pull-effekte
schaffen die den Menschen das Signal
geben du musst nur irgendwie dahin
kommen dann wird diese Regierung dir
schon einen Weg eröffnen wie du auf
Dauer Deutschland bleiben kann das ist
nicht unsere Politik liebe Freundinnen
und Freunde das werden wir nicht
akzeptieren
wir brauchen Einwanderung wir brauchen
vor allem
fachkräfteeinwanderung und da sagt doch
bitte niemand da sei in den letzten
Jahren nicht schon viel geschehen ist ja
ohnehin ein Vorwurf den wir immer wieder
und ständig hören ich habe es eben schon
mal kurz angesprochen diese
schrecklichen 16 Jahre die wir da
regiert haben in diesen 16 Jahren hat es
mehrfache Änderungen des
Aufenthaltsrechts gegeben mehrfacher
Änderungen der Einwanderung wirklich
echte gute Entscheidungen gegeben für
Fachkräfte Einwanderung wir sind heute
nach den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
das Land proportional zur Bevölkerung
das mit die höchsten Einwanderungszahlen
in den Arbeitsmarkt hat das haben wir
gemacht liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
dafür brauchen wir uns nicht zu
entschuldigen und ich lehne es ab dass
wir ständig mit dem Vorwurf konfrontiert
werden die seien und vergeudete
vergammelte 16 Jahre gewesen in
Deutschland nein liebe Freundinnen
Freunde nicht die letzten 16 Jahre waren
das Problem die letzten 16 Wochen sind
das Problem bei dieser Regierung die wir
da im Amt haben willkommen mit ihren
Entscheidungen nicht weiter weil sie
sich ständig gegenseitig blockieren
und dann das letzte Thema dass ich
ansprechen möchte damit wir uns darüber
verständigen dass dies ein Thema wird
das wir zu unserem Thema machen müssen
wissen dass das nicht alle
übereinstimmend so sehen wie ich es
jetzt vielleicht hier Vortrage aber ist
es richtig dass wir eine Bundesregierung
sehen die sich jetzt auf den Weg macht
Cannabis in Deutschland freizugeben
liebe Freundinnen Freunde schauen Sie
mal ich wohne an der in der Nähe zur
niederländischen Grenze wir sind relativ
viel in Holland kennen das Land
einigermaßen da sind fünf Gramm
freigegeben mit fatalen Folgen für die
Bevölkerung insbesondere für die junge
Generation jetzt will Herr Lauterbach 30
Gramm freigeben in Deutschland und den
privaten Anbau genehmigen was hat der
Mann eigentlich geraucht dass der nach
diesen Einschränkungen von Corona nein
liebe ich meine das ganz ernst
ich meine das sehr ernst wissen Sie
die corona-einschränkungen
die corona-einschränkungen die wir jetzt
seit zweieinhalb Jahren erleben erleben
müssen auch hinnehmen mussten konnten
wenn es nach Lauterbach geht überhaupt
nicht streng genug sein Schulen zu
Universitäten zu Altenheime keine
Besuche mehr die Menschen mussten dort
sterben ohne Begleitung durch ihre
Angehörige alles geschlossen überall die
Maske das ganze Land verkleidet
irre ein Mann der offensichtlich wie
spät nachts an seinem Computer sitzt und
irgendwelche Studien liest und dann
morgens benebelt in den Bundestag kommt
mit neuen Vorschlägen was er dann alles
noch in diesem Lande einschränken will
Gott sei Dank gibt es Landesregierungen
die sich dagegen ausreichend und
hinreichend gewährt haben auch ihre aber
dann auf der anderen Seite jetzt in
diesem Umfang Rauschmittel freizugeben
rauschgiftfrei zu geben unsere Kinder
diesen Gefährdungen auszusetzen ich sage
meine Damen und Herren nicht mit unseren
Kindern das lassen wir nicht zu dass so
etwas in diesem Lande geschieht und wir
werden alles mobilisieren dass das
verhindert wird was da jetzt gerade
stattfindet
und so sehen Sie
dass wir eine ganze Reihe von Themen
haben
dort wo wir in der politischen
Verantwortung stehen in den
Landesregierungen arbeiten wir eng und
vertrauensvoll zusammen
wir wollen das im nächsten Jahr so
bleibt und vielleicht sogar in zwei
Städten Berlin und Bremen neue
CDU-geführte Landesregierungen
hinzukommen
sie wissen es in Berlin muss eine ganze
Abgeordnetenhauswahl wiederholt werden
weil dieser Senat in Berlin nicht in der
Lage war eine ganz normale
Abgeordnetenhauswahl zu organisieren ich
sehe hier Daniela Ludwig die Vorsitzende
des wahlprüfungsausschusses lassen Sie
sich von ihrer Kollegin mal erzählen was
sich da zugetragen hat meine Damen und
Herren das sind Zeichen einer
Bananenrepublik die da stattfinden das
ist unwürdig für ein Land das sich
Demokratie parlamentarische Demokratie
nennt was dieser Berliner Senat da
angezettelt hat
da wird es Neuwahlen geben genauso wie
in Bremen aber dann eben auch in Hessen
und in Bayern und liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde ich möchte dass wir mit großer
Geschlossenheit aus diesem Land aus
diesem Jahr 2022 herausgehen und dass
wir in unserem Land mit großer
Geschlossenheit in das Jahr 2023
hineingehen
wir sind unschlagbar wenn wir
zusammenhalten
wir sind meine Damen und Herren und
bleiben
die führende politische Kraft unseres
Landes
konservativ liberal und sozial das sind
die drei Wurzeln unserer beiden Parteien
alles drei gehört dazu und die Menschen
draußen warten hier auf ein klares
Signal und eine klare
Positionsbestimmung von uns und ich
werde mich dabei nicht beirren lassen
von denen die uns aus Medien oder
sonstigen Schreibstuben irgendwelche
klugen Ratschläge geben die meisten von
denen die uns diese Ratschläge gegeben
haben in ihrem Leben noch nie die Union
gewählt die CSU in Bayern nicht und die
CDU auch im Rest der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland nicht nein wir müssen
unseren Kompost schon selber neu
ausrichten wir müssen schon selbst sagen
was wir für die Zukunft unseres Landes
für Vorstellungen haben und wenn wir das
gemeinsam machen dann gehen wir aus dem
Jahr 2023 genauso gut und erfolgreich
heraus wie aus dem Jahr 2022 hoffentlich
mit etwas weniger Krise hoffentlich
endlich mit gelösten Problemen für die
privaten Haushalte und die Unternehmen
aber vor allem mit einer gestärkten CSU
und mit einem Minister Patienten Markus
Söder der in Bayern einen guten großen
eindrucksvollen Wählerauftrag bekommt
lieber Markus wir werden dir dabei
helfen genauso wie Du uns hilfst dass
sie in Deutschland gemeinsam Wahlen
gewinnen und so machen wir uns in
Geschlossenheit gemeinsam auf diesem Weg
ich freue mich richtig auf die weitere
gute Zusammenarbeit mit Ihnen liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde der CSU
herzlichen Dank